hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
aspects of Rene de cartes
meditation number four that I think some
modern readers may find a bit puzzling
or confusing is his discussion of how
the human being which is the The
Enquirer the one who's engaging in some
self-reflection
in these meditations is caught in
between two different ends we might say
of the spectrum of being with the
Supreme Being or God on one side and
what he describes as nothingness Nant or
non being no net on the other side and
really what we ought to do if we want to
understand this properly within a
context of the history of ideas is
instead of seeing it as a continuum like
this we should flip it so that Supreme
Being is at the top and non-being is at
the non bottom you might say all right
there's nothing down there quite
literally and then everything else is
gradations in between and the human
being is set in between those in some
respect so Descartes begins this
meditation by you know he's interested
in how do I go wrong
how do I make errors how do I make
mistakes is another way we can translate
right so he says that I find within
myself a certain capacity or power of
judging which I doubtless received from
God and then he talks about how God
would not set him up to be deceived so
how is he deceived them well this this
whole business of thinking about where
human being fits in is part of that that
picture of answering this question well
how do I actually go wrong so he's going
to talk about two ideas that he has that
he's had the entire time and now he's
managed to bring to light over the
course of his meditations and which he's
now going to look at more closely in
order to understand where he fits him so
he talks about having a real and
positive you could translate real as
actual if you want a real and positive
idea of God in meditation 3 he talked
about this in terms of actually
providing a proof for God's existence
this this idea is something like a mark
that the workman places upon his product
and the product here is the human mind
so we have an idea of God according to
Descartes that is within our mind so
what is this real and positive idea of
God it's very important actually that we
stress this notion of the being a
positive idea because in some of the
objections some of the commentators are
going to say oh you know you talk about
this infinite being but your your notion
of infinity is basically just like a
primitive idea you're taking away all
sorts of limitations and then you you
have this kind of fuzzy concept in your
mind Descartes is saying no no no I have
an idea of God as a being as he says a
supremely perfect being in other places
he'll talk about this
as a being lacking none of the
perfections of being possessing all of
the perfections and we might want to
think for just a moment what is a
perfection a perfection is something
that it is better to be than not to be
that's you know not take hearts actual
formulation that goes all the way back
to Anselm of Canterbury discussing the
divine attributes but I think it's
perfectly apt right here to think of it
in that way so anything that's good
anything that's that's describing you
know fullness or perfection you know
that is what God actually is so he says
when I think about God I don't discover
in myself any cause of error or falsity
right I have this this is he says I I
remarkable idea of God or better yet a
being whose sovereign you know
sovereignly or supremely perfect souffle
animal parfait but also I have another
idea that's at the other end of the
spectrum I have he says something that
could be said Posse parlay a certain
idea that is negative a negative idea of
what of nothingness naos and why I
translated is nothingness because it's
not an idea of nothing yeah it's an idea
of what it is to be nothing this is a
little bit harder to wrap your head
around
I mean wrapping your head around what
exactly God is that's already quite
difficult but thinking nothingness
that's also quite difficult as well and
then it you know if we want a little bit
of clarification to try to help us out
he does provide some right here he tells
us that it is what is infinitely
distance a looong yay
French from every kind or type or sort
of perfection right and he says it's
infinitely distanced from that so
however much you can think of something
as being without a perfection of
perfection being something like goodness
or being or truth or power or whatever
it is that you want to think about
however much you think about it it's
even further than that is another way of
conceptualizing it so you really can't
wrap your head around this adequately
and yet take heart says that there is a
certain idea of this in our mind this is
a negative this is a primitive idea as
opposed to that of God so he says that I
myself here's the third key point and
sort of a middle ground in middle you
between God and nothingness that is to
say I am placed in some way between the
sovereign being God and non-being no net
and he says that you know within me
killed mr. hong kong's of the nm WA came
a priest Condor we're down there there's
nothing within me that's that's going to
lead me to error X you know in in so far
as the sovereign being has produced me
so God didn't make me ready to go astray
or liable to go astray
but because I'm positioned between
Supreme Being infinite perfection
infinite sum of perfections and
non-being it's possible for me to go
astray for me to err for me to fall into
mistakes so he says if I consider myself
as participating and notice he has to
hedge
a bit here in some manner on calculus
all right in in nothingness or in
non-being that is to say in so far as I
am NOT myself the sovereign being he
says I find within myself an infinity of
here's an interesting word an infinity
of lakhs an infinity of deficits
monkeyball in French you know monk eight
means to be missing
and so there's things that ought to be
there that aren't there
and those derive from this nothingness I
participate somehow he doesn't clarify
what participating and nothingness
actually means but it's it's perhaps a
metaphorical term he participates in
nothingness
every time that he's making some sort of
mistake because there is this in
affinity of lakhs within himself and we
can say that's within human being
insofar as Descartes himself is saying
that listen you can stand in as the
human being in these meditations right
but he's really just thinking about his
this is a reflexive process of
considering his own being so if you
think that you perhaps are the sovereign
being or that you you know don't have
any of these lacks well maybe this isn't
for you but for the rest of us who can
recognize that we we are not the supreme
being and that maybe there are some
lacks within ourselves this is something
to think about now a little bit later in
this this meditation he's going to say
that error is not pure negation in us so
he says it's not simply the defect or
the lack of sort of some sort of
perfection which is not applicable to me
is not expected of me icky he uses the
term do
you know something that I should have
right buddy says rather it's a privation
of some knowledge some Kony songs that
it seems that I ought to possess and so
where error is arising is when we're
participating in some way in nothingness
or non-being by lacking within ourselves
a knowledge that ought to belong to us
and we can consider then how it is that
we fall into this lack of knowledge and
that's what we're looking at in the rest
of this meditation but it's important to
understand this very metaphysical
grounding for error
we are placed according to Descartes in
between whatever the Supreme Being is of
which we have some idea and whatever non
being or nothingness is we are that
thing in between as human being
you